welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my flash season 6 episode 2
video there was a whole bunch of crisis
on Infinite Earths moments foreshadowing
and big teasers for even the back half
of the season so we'll break it all down
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about crisis on the video careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the
episode will do top 10 and Easter
eggs so starting with number 10 blood
work uses his powers for the first time
unwittingly but it pretty much works the
same way it does in the comics he's able
to control the blood of other people
he doesn't investigate and find out
what's going on till the end of the
episode but the way they're playing the
character is pretty much the way they
played the character on the heroes TV
show where he starts out as this good
person wanting to help people but
through his actions is slowly pushed to
violence so all that's gonna play out in
the first half of the season but he's
only meant to be around for the first
half of the season I think we actually
got a teaser for the villain the second
half of the season in the episode -
there's a whole subplot with
frost they give her a Ray Palmer
designed in a night cocktail that's
gonna help her the rest of the season
it's just gonna make it easier for the
actress danielle Panabaker to walk
around as frost
without having to wear those contacts in
her eyes the entire time I hundred
percent think that plot point is just to
make it more comfortable for the actress
and has nothing to do with her actually
fitting in with normal people but number
nine they introduce allegra garcia new
character i don't know how long she's
going to be around because she's
obviously sticks around at the end with
that internship but she is a comic book
character from the titans comics the way
her cousin manipulates the
electromagnetic spectrum to heat stuff
up is actually what her comic book
powers are so they gave that to her
cousin and they made her powers
controlling radio waves that'll probably
come in handy if she comes back for
another episode when she's investigating
stuff for iris in the central city
citizen number 8 Barry finally makes
himself a version of giddy and everyone
wondering if he was going to create
giddy in this season but I think the
mobile version of Gideon is what they
were talking about there might be a more
advanced version of that that he
upgrades later this season but for now I
think that's what that was him just
created the mobile version that he can
carry around with himself and I'm still
really happy that Morena Baccarin is
doing the voice of the character but
anytime Barry says that he's gonna
travel to the future without telling
team flash and he's not wearing his
flash costume you automatically know
something terrible is going to happen so
number seven the antimatter barrier when
he approaches December 10th the crisis
state he just bounces right off of this
wall that they later learned is pure
antimatter as if the entire multiverse
has been converted to antimatter energy
and that's why he can't use the Speed
Force to travel through it enter Jay
Garrick but as you've seen so far on all
the TV shows the way they're playing
crisis right now is if at this moment in
present day they're still going to lose
in the future until something changes
they kept trying to say that during the
episode will change the future will do
something different we can't I have to
die
so part of the big twist of crisis this
year is going to be finding a way out of
that situation I'm not expecting to have
a really easy answer but we'll start to
find out what that is through arrow
because it sounds like Oliver Queen is
going to do something that will help
save the multiverse so even if the flash
does wind up dying he will do something
that will allow him to come back it's
gonna get way twistier before it gets
way simpler but it's gonna be a couple
more episodes before we have more
evidence for a really good theory number
six welcome back Jay Garrick formerly
known as the flash of earth 3 it kind of
hurt me to hear that but remember last
season he teased that he'd be training a
new speedster made it sound like it was
a female speedster to take his place but
we don't know who that is yet he
jokingly references the coffee cup a
little bit when he's talking about Barry
traveling into the future what are you
doing time-traveling kid but then twist
says you probably did the right thing
when he says he's been detecting
antimatter signatures all over the
multiverse for the past year what he's
talking about is the anti-monitor in his
servants popping up all over the
multiverse trying to influence people
remember how the monitor has been
traveling around like a genie popping up
telling Oliver you need to come help me
we have to go to these different places
to assemble heroes and start working to
fight the anti-monitor
the anti-monitor is doing the same thing
with his own minions this map is
beautiful I hope that they sell a
version of this it'd be really cool to
get a giant printout to this but you see
pretty much all the earths that we've
been to before marked there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs here zoom and
enhance here's breachers earth here
supergirls earth 38 jay garrick's earth
3 wells the gray way over here on the
side you see the source wall around the
multiverse you see Earth's that are
designated way higher than 52 like earth
221 here I might even have to do a
separate video just for the Easter eggs
on this there are so many there's even
an earth with a question mark
unknown earth so they're just trying to
let you know there's gonna be a couple
big reveals during crisis on Infinite
Earths I wouldn't be surprised if the
question mark earth winds up being the
Smallville earth with Tom Welling
Superman but I have a feeling that some
of these will be revealed during the
crossover where it's as earth destroyed
in 1986 it's either earth 75 or earth 15
that it's referring to it's not totally
clear that was the date when the crisis
on Infinite Earths comic book was
originally published worlds will live
worlds will die so the same thing will
happen during this year's crossover they
will actually blow up some of the
Earth's in the multiverse the other big
Easter Egg that really stands out here
is the fattiest brown one up top here if
your big comic book reader you recognize
daddy is brown as mr. miracle so they
might be teasing some special new gods
stuff happening this season because of
crisis on Infinite Earths
it feels like those are really huge
characters and this is such a big event
you would want to invoke them somehow
and the arrowverse in this way the fact
that there's a red arrow pointing to
earth 2 is actually something that they
address on the arrow TV show that'll be
part of my trailer video tomorrow
because they do a whole bunch of
multiverse stuff during the arrow
episode but number 5 berry meets another
version of his mother and almost passes
out in the process he kind of mouths the
words mom and it's almost the same
reaction that he had when he saw Jay
Garrick for the first time dad I'm not
your dad Barry the reason why Jay
Garrick doesn't know that Joan looks
just like Barry's mother is probably
just because Barry didn't tell him and
Jay Garrick never met Barry's parents so
he wouldn't know that he married
basically the same woman as his
doppelganger did on earth 1 but like I
said during all the trailer videos that
I did she's basically meant to be a
version of Tina McGee the scientist
that's helping Jay Garrick but obviously
what he's doing now is mostly research
and less of being a speedster elongated
man tells this weird story about how his
mother dated a trapeze artist that could
be a reference to the flying Grayson's
because there have been rumors about
Titans appearing during crisis on
Infinite Earths this year but it's just
a rumor
moving under number 4 Barry uses Jay
Garrick's device to send his
consciousness into the future so
obviously they're using his helmet so it
just looks awake
cooller him wearing jay garrick's helmet
and sending his consciousness through
the antimatter barrier but you can kind
of see the way he visualizes it he's
actually running this is all just
happening in his mind though so what
he's witnessing here is the antimatter
wave of the anti monitors powers
detonating consuming everything
converting all positive matter in the
multiverse into antimatter he comes out
and they get the Avengers Infinity Ward
Doctor Strange quote one one time line
in billions where we survived because I
died he makes his peace with it by the
end of the episode but then he says we
have to start preparing everyone for a
world without the flash which is a
reference for world without a Superman
which is the name of the comic book that
they publish after the death of Superman
they had a big funeral for him that was
called funeral for a friend then you had
a world without a Superman then you had
reign of the Superman they have the
funny lady gaga joke when he wakes up to
John reading him the poem by William
Knox a flash of the lightning it's a
beautiful poem but a flash of the
lightning is also the title of the comic
book issue where the flash died during
crisis on Infinite Earths they even
referenced this comic book panel here
where he's sort of disintegrating into
nothingness after he destroys the
anti-monitor his gun by running so fast
that's what this is meant to be he's
witnessing his own death they did a
pretty good job of trying to sync up the
themes of all the different storylines
like Joe West gives in the explainer
later about his badges their emblems of
the symbols of strength were charged
with charged like the flash is literally
charged with electricity when you hear
the call of duty you have to be willing
to make the sacrifice this is a brief
Game of Thrones reference where cisco
makes fun of frost calling her a
white walker they try to have this whole
comedic subplot about her trying to
learn to be a normal person the picture
that she's trying to draw though is
actually a representation of the goddess
that her father believed in that she's
based on the sort of mythological
northern figure so it's frost
trying to address the grief that she has
over the death of her father but number
three really huge teaser for a comic
book villain group black hole so when
they're learning about Allegra's
cousin's body being taken by a mystery
group we don't know what happened you
see the symbol on their jackets it's the
symbol of black hole from the flash
rebirth comic books they're able to take
her cousin down but the whole point here
is just in setting up the concept that
there is a secret organization if it's
called black hole
that's using metas to their advantage I
don't know how much is going to be like
the comic book version of black hole
because in the comics their main goal
was to exploit the Speed Force and they
were in this secret alliance with
Gorilla Grodd I don't know if they're
gonna be doing any of that stuff they
might just be setting up black hole as
this evil organization they might also
choose to introduce Ryan because he's
one of the big evil speedsters that's
part of that group number two big teaser
for future things to come potentially
they talk about ultraviolet light it's
80 times faster than your top speed
berry in the comics colors of lightning
usually denote different levels of speed
so the idea that the ultraviolet
wavelength is 80 times faster than
normal
lightning remember flash utilizes
lightning speed force dark matter energy
might come in handy when Barry is trying
to save the day during crisis on
Infinite Earths so that might come back
around just pay attention to that the
whole concept of him traveling way
beyond his normal levels of speed Jay
Garrick takes off back to earth 3 with
Joan they're just letting you know that
they'll come back later this season
there will be more Jay Garrick during
flash season 6 and yes Wally West will
come back but it's gonna be during the
second half of the season he will not be
around for crisis on Infinite Earths
number one though obviously the
post-credits scene blood work studying
the effects of his abilities when his
victim turns into a zombie in search to
go I'll Hulk on every one so it's gonna
be the villain of next week's episode or
one of the villains the whole idea
though is that blood work himself is
capable of controlling these constructs
so I think that he'll probably learned
that at some point during the episode oh
wait he's not fighting me I have the
ability to control this giant Gollum but
post all your theories in the comments
below I know you probably have a
thousand questions about all the crisis
on Infinite Earths scene so I'll try to
address that during my trailer video for
episode 3 tomorrow and arrow is back
tonight arrow season 8 episode 1 I'll
try to include any big crisis stuff
during my trailer video tomorrow
including that Batman teaser that they
released earlier today I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post my trailer
video tomorrow everybody click here for
my flash episode 1 video and everybody
click here for my flash Batman teaser
video for crisis on Infinite
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight